Speaker 1: Some absolutely unbelievable deposition
transcripts have been published and they relate to
very dangerous fruit. It appears as though, you
know, Donald Trump remember when he kept talking
about the oranges of an investigation.
Speaker 2: Take a look at the oranges
of the investigation.
Speaker 1: It looks as though that may not have
been just a verbal glitch. He might actually have
some kind of an irrational fear of fruit. We have
testimony from when Donald Trump gave a videotaped
deposition in October related to a lawsuit filed
by some protesters against the former president's
security staff who are being accused of assault.
And Trump gave a videotaped deposition. And
the topic of dangerous fruit, apparently
almost an obsession for Trump. We're going to
look at a little bit of the deposition transcript
here. Trump was asked. Okay. And you said that if
you see someone getting ready to throw a tomato,
just knock the crap out of them, would you? That
was your statement. And Trump said, Oh, yeah, it
was very dangerous. And Trump was asked what was
very dangerous. And he said, we were threatened.
With what? Trump says they were going to throw
fruit. We were threatened. We had a threat. Trump
was asked, How did you become aware that there was
a threat that people were going to throw fruit?
And Trump said, We were told I thought
Secret Service was involved in that,
actually, but we were told and you get hit with
fruit. It's now it's very violent stuff. We
were on alert for that. The questioner says
a tomato is a fruit after all, I guess. And
and Trump says, and you know what? And
then Mr. A mr. Goldman says it has seeds
to which Trump says it's worse than
tomato. It's other things also,
but tomato. When they start doing that stuff, it's
very dangerous. There was an alert out that day.
Trump was asked, Who were you speaking to
when you said, and Trump says the audience.
And the question then is, so you were speaking
to the audience when you said if they saw
someone getting ready to throw a tomato,
just knock the crap out of them, would you?
And Trump said that was to the audience. It
was said sort of in jest, but maybe, you know,
a little truth. It's very dangerous stuff. You
can get killed with those things. The question is,
so were you trying to incentivize people to
engage in violence? Trump's lawyer objects.
And then Trump says, No, I wanted to have
people be ready because we were put on alert
that they were going to do fruit. And some
fruit is a lot worse than tomatoes are bad,
by the way, but it's very dangerous. Very, very
dangerous. Now, I do want to say it is absolutely
true that a tomato is a fruit. Fruit is the
sweet and fleshy product of a tree or plant
that can sane, contains seeds and can be eaten as
food. And when you talk about a tomato, the fruit
grows from the flower of the tomato plant and thus
tomatoes are indeed fruits. I would make the case
that the most dangerous fruit would technically be
a pumpkin. A pumpkin both is a fruit, which a lot
of people don't know. But it is. And the record
heaviest fruit in the world was a 20 £600 pumpkin
that could easily kill someone. I mean, that's
like dropping a small car on someone. The trick
would be, of course, picking it up and how you
pick it up. I don't know, guys, this is crazy
fruit. They were put on notice about fruit. And
it reminds me of the great film Mrs. Doubtfire,
of course, with the late Robin Williams, the
infamous scene of the run by Fruiting, where
a mrs. Doubtfire throws a lime at the back of
the head of a Pierce Brosnan's character. And
there's also for film buffs out there, there is a
very famous continuity error in that scene where
Robin Williams character, as Mrs. Doubtfire takes
a lime and throws it. And then when the cut goes
back to Robin Williams, that very lime that he
she through is back on the pile of limes. This
is a true film buff thing for those who care
about this type of trivia, but very strange,
a very bizarre obsession on the dangers of fruit.
Uh, there it is. And maybe this relates to Trump
and flushing toilets 10 to 15 times somehow. If
it says anything about his diet. I don't know.